la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion sur le rapport de
la commission mixte paritaire du projet
de loi relatif à la programmation
militaire pour les années 2024 à 2030 et
portant diverses dispositions
intéressantes à défense
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Michel
Jacques rapporteur de la commission
mixte paritaire
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
lorsque nous avions commencé l'examen de
ce projet de loi de programmation
militaire j'avais émis un vœu que chacun
d'entre nous soit guidé par une seule
boussole
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation
au regard des débats qui ont animé
l'examen de ce texte en commission comme
en hémicycle à l'Assemblée comme au
Sénat je pense que mon vœu a été
largement réalisé
au-delà des intérêts partisans nous
avons su nous réunir pour nos armées
nous pouvons collectivement nous réjouir
que l'ensemble des débats était
constructif et qu'ils aient permis
d'enrichir considérablement ce texte
je pense bien sûr à l'augmentation des
marches budgétaires en début de LPM pour
permettre d'intensifier la préparation
opérationnelle dès 2024 tout en
sécurisant les ressources extra
budgétaires je pense à l'effort consenti
pour la rémunération de nos militaires
avec la révision programmée des grilles
indiciaires nécessaires pour relever le
défi de la fidélisation
je pense également bien entendu au
renforcement du rôle du Parlement avec
le principe d'une loi pour
l'actualisation avec un droit
d'information amélioré sur les
ajustements annuels et les grands
programmes de coopération européenne ou
encore avec la création d'une nouvelle
commission
parlementaire sur les exportations
je pense enfin aux avancées sur le
financement de notre industrie de
défense à travers la mobilisation du
système bancaire
ces avancées n'auraient pas pu être
possible sans l'implication de tous
je salue l'investissement des députés de
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
qui a permis d'avoir un niveau de débat
élevé et toujours respectueux je tiens
également à saluer chaleureusement notre
collègue Sabine Tillier
rapporteur des articles 32 à 35 bis et
qui a assuré son rôle avec une grande
efficacité
je remercie bien entendu l'ensemble des
membres de la commission mix paritaire
et en premier lieu le président
rapporteur du Sénat Christian Kombat
les négociations ont pu être âpres mais
elles ont toujours été constructives et
cordialement
enfin en tant que rapporteur monsieur le
ministre je tiens à vous remercier pour
votre engagement sincère ainsi que pour
votre écoute et votre disponibilité qui
a été reconnu par tous les par tous les
parlementaires qui ont participé au
débat
mes chers collègues au-delà de
l'enrichissement du texte par le
Parlement je voudrais rappeler combien
ce texte engage notre nation
plus que jamais à l'heure de l'agression
russe de la stratégie de puissance de la
Chine de la persistance des risques
terroristes ou de la multiplication des
menaces hybrides chacun d'entre nous
inconscience de l'importance du rôle de
nos armées pour nous protéger et pour
faire entendre la voix de la France
aujourd'hui le texte sur lequel nous
sommes appelés à nous prononcer en temps
à répondre à ses défis en portant une
ambition à la hauteur des enjeux
413 milliards d'euros c'est un signal
fort que nous envoyons à nos armées mais
aussi à nos compétiteurs stratégiques
c'est également une chance pour nos
territoires qui bénéficieront de
nombreuses retombées économiques de
cette LPM
mes chers collègues comme à chaque année
à l'occasion du 14 juillet les
Françaises et les Français célèbrent nos
valeurs soldats
nous savons ce que nous leur devons
dès lors c'est vote est plus que jamais
le symbole de la reconnaissance de la
Nation envers ces femmes et ses hommes
civils et militaires qui sont la grande
richesse de nos armées alors mes chers
collègues bon votent et vive l'Armée
française je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas gassilou
pour président de la Commission de la
Défense nationale et des forces armées
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre tout juste rentré d'ailleurs du
sommet de l'OTAN à Vilnius mes chers
collègues je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes réunis à un moment important de
la 16e législature dans un monde où les
mutations technologiques s'accélèrent ou
le droit international est remis en
cause par la force des armes nous sommes
sur le point de voter la poursuite d'un
effort historique engagé dès 2018 pour
nous armées en tant que président de la
Commission de la Défense nationale et
des forces armées de notre assemblée je
me permettrait simplement trois
remarques d'abord sur le montant et le
contenu de cette LPM les orateurs qui me
suivront auront l'occasion de revenir
sur le détail de cette LPM 400 milliards
de crédit c'est un effort considérable à
la hauteur des menaces qui sont
elles-mêmes considérable entre 2017 et
2030 nous aurons plus que doublé notre
budget annuel de défense pour permettre
à nos armées de pouvoir agir plus vite
plus fort plus loin dans des milieux
toujours plus nombreux pour protéger les
Français en France ou partout ce sera
nécessaire comme récemment à cartoon
dans le cadre de l'opération Sagittaire
ma deuxième remarque concerne la méthode
des d'allaborations de cette LPM une
échappe à personne que notre situation
politique est complexe mais le processus
d'adoption de la LPM démontre que nous
pouvons dépasser nos désaccords et nous
rassembler quand l'essentiel est en jeu
le travail sur cette LPM fut un grand
moment démocratique si notre commission
de la défense s'y est préparé depuis des
mois le débat a été élargi bien au-delà
puisque j'ai choisi déléguer plusieurs
articles à la commission des lois
puisque la commission des affaires
étrangères et la commission des finances
s'ils sont saisis pour avis puisque j'ai
demandé à l'OPEX de produire un rapport
sur l'évaluation des retombées civiles
de l'innovation militaire et puisque
même la commission des affaires
européennes il y a travaillé plus de 4
commissions sur les 8 ion travaillé
toutes les oppositions étaient entendues
chacune a pu faire adopter des
propositions avec souvent un regard
bienveillons de notre ministre les
travaux au Sénat puis en commission
mixparitaire ce lundi ont confirmé que
nous pouvions bâtir ensemble pour la
France et pour les Français ce processus
a également été l'occasion de faire
passer les messages très clair à nos
alliés et à nos compétiteurs 3 heures de
débat public sur la dissuasion sur la
conforte la crédibilité et sa durabilité
échanger l'augment sur le rôle de
l'Alliance atlantique et de l'Union
européenne c'est montrer à nos alliés
que nos engagements sont forts car
réfléchit débattus et partagé mais on
dit cela il me faut immédiatement
préciser c'est mon dernier point mes
chers collègues que notre travail ne
fait que commencer d'abord cette
programmation comme vous le savez ne
prendra concrètement ses effets au fur
et à mesure de l'adoption des lois de
finances et de leur parfaite exécution
les huit rapports pour avis de la
commission de la défense il travaille
déjà pour vous fournir leurs avis
formulés à ce sujet dans les prochains
mois et je compte sur chacun d'entre
vous pour être fidèle aux engagements
importants que vous prendrez ce jour
devant les Français par ailleurs si
depuis la fin de la guerre froide nous
avons non seulement des investis dans
notre appareil militaire c'est ce qu'on
a appelé les dividendes de la paix nous
avons également beaucoup des appris en
matière de défense globale ce que
l'Ukraine nous apprend ce que l'Ukraine
nous réapprend ce qu'il n'y a pas de
défense efficace en application de la
nation tout entière c'est pourquoi il
nous reste à faire en sorte que chaque
citoyen quel que soit ses capacités se
sentent impliquées je dirais même
engager dans notre défense nationale en
d'autres termes mes chers collègues la
LPM ne représente que le noyau
capacitaire de notre défense nationale
qui pourrait être efficace doit
s'élargir à l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de la nation du citoyen en
passant par les collectivités
territoriales les entreprises jusqu'au
ministère qu'il faut remobiliser dans
une approche interministérielle des
questions de défense c'est vrai de
l'économie au transport de l'énergie à
la santé de la culture l'éducation c'est
en sens que se construit une société
résiliente jamais sur la seule confiance
sur nos armements et je compte aussi sur
vous mes chers collègues pour que chacun
d'entre vous soit acteur du
développement d'une culture de défense
pour notre pays en conclusion mes chers
collègues nous ne pourrons que être très
satisfait de cette LPM que vous je vous
invite à voter mais le travail pour
renforcer notre défense nationale le
fait que commencer alors faisons
ensemble je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est à Monsieur Sébastien Lecornu
ministre des Armées
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission de la défense
et des forces armées monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission mixte
paritaire mesdames et messieurs les
députés je tenais à commencer mon propos
par là où je l'avais terminé lors de mon
intervention en discussion générale il y
a maintenant plusieurs semaines en ayant
une pensée pour les femmes et les hommes
qui ont fait le choix de l'engagement au
sein de nos forces armées et tout
particulièrement en cette veille de fête
nationale et donc faites particulières
pour nos blessés nous tuer et leur
famille ainsi qu'aux nombreux civils de
la défense engagés c'est à eux que nous
pensons tout d'abord alors que le
Parlement s'apprête à se prononcer sur
le projet de loi de programmation
militaire pour les années 2024 à 2030
c'est un moment important pour nos
armées lorsque tous les 5 ans 6 ans ou
parfois sept ans le Parlement discute et
vote un projet de loi de programme pour
notre modèle de défense pour fixer un
cap à ce modèle défin dans les effets
militaires que nous souhaitons produire
face aux menaces qui pèsent sur le pays
détailler les missions qui peuvent être
confiées à nos armées et bien entendu ça
a été dit les moyens que nous leur
allons en lien avec nos capacités
industrielles c'est aussi un moment
important pour la nation qui prend la
mesure du rôle fondamental que je ne
militaire pour garantir notre sécurité
notre souveraineté et en fin de compte
peut-être plus simplement notre
prospérité c'est aussi un moment
important enfin pour les puissances
étrangères qui nous observent qu'il
s'agisse de nos alliés mais aussi nos
compétiteurs et qui prennent acte de la
puissance de notre République pour
trouver dans le respect des règles
constitutionnelles qui encadrent les
compétences de chacun les voies et
moyens de répondre aux défis
sécuritaires qui pèse sur la nation
française
mais avant même que la représentation
nationale ne s'exprime sur le texte dans
un instant et entendre les différentes
explications de vote je veux revenir sur
les éléments qui ont permis je le crois
je l'espère que l'examen de ce projet de
loi soit utile pour le débat politique
national sur un sujet singulier avec une
histoire française on l'a rappelé
singulière dans un moment mondial lui
aussi tout autant singulier tout d'abord
si je forme le vœu que ce 15e projet de
loi de programmation militaire depuis la
Cinquième République rencontre le succès
par le vote que vous ferez dans quelques
instants sur les conclusions de la
commission mix paritaire je relève comme
je l'avais fait lors de la discussion
générale que les sujets militaires ne
sont toujours pas consensuels sur des
sujets fondamentaux dans la construction
de notre système de défense je m'avance
d'ailleurs un peu en admettant que ces
projets de loi de programmation aurait
tous été voté à chaque fois puisque sur
les 14 précédents projets loi de
programmation militaire depuis 1960 un
seul n'a pas été votée par le Parlement
en 1992 les sujets de défense sont bien
entendu des sujets politiques au sens
noble du terme avec des modèles et des
visions qui s'affrontent s'agissant de
nos alliances du rôle et de la place
notre dissuasion nucléaire et même sur
la doctrine d'emploi de nos forces
armées en réponse à des menaces dont les
contours ne sont pas toujours pleinement
partagés par tous Je me noore d'avoir pu
mener ces débats avec vous et au cours
de cet examen en apportant aux
françaises et aux Français un éclairage
salutaire sur ce que chaque groupe
politique représentait au sein de cette
émission propose pour notre modèle de
défense les sujets de débats n'ont pas
manqué la force des convictions et des
arguments non plus il faut s'en réjouir
ce débat mesdames messieurs les députés
il est sain et je crois il n'a rien de
médiocre le vote d'adoption parce que
c'est un public de l'Assemblée nationale
a été clair mais il n'a pas
occulté des visions du monde et donc de
notre défense qui sont profondément je
le crois divergente et peut-être même
encore comparablement irréconciliables
entre elles l'examen du texte dans cette
hémicycle a montré que certaines
sensibilités politiques en dépit de
quelques clarifications inédites et
peut-être bienvenu avance toujours dans
une forme de flou notamment sur leur
modèle d'alliance notamment avec nos
partenaires européens et nord-atlantique
ou sur leur position définitive et sans
ambiguïté sur le rôle et l'efficacité de
notre dissuasion nucléaire les trois
semaines de débat l'Assemblée en
commission pu en séance publique nous
ont permis d'entendre les critiques
faites et certaines sont à entendre et à
prendre très clairement en compte
naturellement sur le fonctionnement du
modèle français actuel pour autant les
débats n'ont pas toujours fait émerger
de contre-propositions crédibles et
réalistes sur des sujets pourtant aussi
essentiels que nos alliances militaires
bilatérales comme multilatérales avec
bien entendu la question de notre place
et notre rôle dans le temps mais aussi
du bilan objectif de ce qui a été fait
et accompli par nos forces armées ces
dernières années en Afrique et de la
voiture à adopter de manière courageuse
et pragmatique en matière de lutte
contre le terrorisme je tiens enfin à
collectivement vous remercier du débat
que nous avons eu sur la dissuasion
nucléaire celui-ci fut d'une très grande
qualité certaines positions sont
clairement irréconscillables mais c'est
le nord d'une grande démocratie que de
permettre de les exprimer de les
confronter la discussion a eu un écho
bien au-delà de l'hémicycle puisqu'elle
a été largement suivie par différents
observateurs qui ont tous estimé qu'il
n'avaient pas eu lieu dans ce format
avec cette liberté avec cette technicité
depuis les débats initiaux portés ici
même par Pierre Messmer et les
différents groupes politiques élus dans
les années 60 nous sommes une démocratie
nucléaire et je crois même que ces
débats n'ont pas eu lieu sous cette
forme chez beaucoup de nos alliés
puissances dotés cela vaut si je peux me
permettre peut-être tous les livres
blancs du monde la question des
coopérations industrielles avec nos
partenaires a également été largement
débattus ce qui permis de réaffirmer la
ligne de conduite de ce gouvernement qui
je dois le dire au fond et peut-être
plus convergente et plus consensuelle
que je ne le pensais dans l'hémicycle
c'est-à-dire de faire toujours primer
l'intérêt de la France en ce qui
concerne les choix que nous faisons et
que nous continuerons de faire je me
suis engagé mesdames messieurs les
députés à revenir devant le Parlement à
chaque fois que nous nous engagerons
dans une nouvelle phase de coopération
notamment sur les programmes SCAF et
mgcs je le ferai et je suis persuadé
mesdames messieurs les députés que cela
permettra d'objectiver les critères et
les paramètres sur lesquels les
décisions devront être prises demain
pour défendre toujours notre intérêt
général mesdames messieurs les députés
l'ensemble de ces sujets sont
déterminants je le disais il me semble
qu'il mérite un débat qui dépasse
désormais les murs du Parlement pour
emmener la nation et nos concitoyens sur
la compréhension de ce modèle d'armée à
l'histoire singulière je le disais et
qui objectifent les menaces qui pèsent
sur la France ce n'est pas tant d'un
débat entre experts dont nous avons
besoin désormais qu'à débat plus
national et peut-être même plus
populaires j'aurais l'occasion d'y
revenir prochainement en tout état de
cause je pense pouvoir affirmer dans le
respect de la séparation des pouvoirs et
du rôle que nous constituons ont donné à
chacun en matière de défense nationale
que cet Assemblée nationale cette
législature a trouvé toute sa place dans
ce débat et qu'elle en sort largement
renforcée les dispositions adoptées
viendront consolider notamment le
contrôle du Parlement sur l'exécution et
l'actualisation de cette programmation
notamment chaque année en amont de
l'examen des projets de loi de finances
qui restent on le sait les véritables
actes parlementaires pour engager
concrètement les crédits pour nos armées
ce renforcement du contrôle
parlementaire permettra aux deux
chambres de tenir un rôle essentiel dans
la poursuite de la montée en puissance
de notre format d'armée dans les
orientations qu'il faudra leur donner je
me réjouis de ces avancées elles sont
inédites sous la 5ème République c'est
un signal important envoyé à ceux qui
pourraient douter de la vitalité de
notre modèle démocratique mais aussi nos
institutions de la Cinquième République
il permettra au Parlement vous assurer
que les choix fait en 2023 que vous
apprêtez à valider seront toujours
adaptés à l'évolution des menaces au
long de la période de programmation trop
souvent dans le passé l'observance
stricte pour ne pas dire scolaire de la
programmation nous a conduit à prendre
des retards ou prendre des décisions
trop tardivement je ne reviendrai pas
sur le bon débat que nous avons eu sur
nos aventures en matière de drone dans
le respect des grands principes de la
Cinquième République il est donc évident
que le moment dans lequel nous nous
trouvons permet au Parlement de trouver
sa place dans notre politique de défense
la qualité des débats que nous avons eu
nous oblige d'ores et déjà pour l'avenir
et ça a été rappelé par le président de
la commission et le rapporteur
enfin le succès de cette loi de
programme qui je l'espère vous voterez
définitivement dans un instant tiens à
une forme de responsabilité que chacun a
su prendre pour définir une trajectoire
budgétaire au service d'une ambition
militaire documentée et crédible
c'est-à-dire de financer des capacités
d'agir concrètes afin d'assurer la
défense aux intérêts de répondre menaces
actuelles mais aussi et peut-être
surtout futur dans tous les espaces de
conflictualité c'est là aussi peut-être
le cœur de la transformation de cette
loi de programme les débats ont été
longs et nombreux pour aboutir aux
compromis trouver lundi dernier en
commission mix paritaire afin d'assurer
à nos militaires les moyens des missions
que nous leur confions ce compromis
permet je le pense de répondre à
l'indispensable besoin de cohérence sur
lequel je ne reviens pas pour notre
modèle d'armée d'emploi c'est-à-dire de
mieux équiper mieux former mieux
soutenir plus recruter mieux fidéliser
et plus s'entraîner nos forces tout en
nous assurant de soutenabilité de la
trajectoire pour nos finances publiques
dans la durée le Parlement dans ce
compromis paritaire à tous égards a
souhaité que nous mettions davantage de
moyens au début de la période sans pour
autant ce qui n'aurait eu je le redis
ici aucun sens alourdir la facture
globale des 400 milliards d'euros de
crédit budgétaire et changer la
programmation des 413 milliards d'euros
nous l'avons entendu et nous sommes
parvenus à cet accord je crois que c'est
une bonne chose mesdames et messieurs
les députés je ne considère pas que
cette programmation militaire comme un
temps un aboutissement cette fruit de
l'engagement du président de la
République chef des armées qui depuis ce
sont élection en 2017 à garder intact sa
volonté de permettre à nos armées de se
réparer puis de se transformer tout cela
avant même je le rappelle que n'éclate
la guerre en Ukraine ce vote ne doit pas
non plus acter de la fin des débats sur
ces sujets militaires un débat plus
national que j'évoquais il y a un
instant s'ajoutent des débats et des
travaux à tenir ici même dans ressembler
ou en commission sur différents sujets
clés pour la réussite de nos objectifs
je me suis engagé mesdames messieurs les
députés pour la discussion parlementaire
à produire un certain nombre de rapports
et à venir en débattre avec vous je
pense notamment en rapport sur
l'évaluation la réintégration du
commandement intégré de l'OTAN acté en
2008 une demande qui provenait de
nombreux bancs je crois qu'il faut
désormais objectiver les choses avec une
approche la plus technique possible la
plus diplomatique mais aussi la plus
militaire possible et je suis heureux de
le faire en tout cas de nous permettre
collectivement de le faire le contrôle
démocratique sur nos services de
renseignement est aussi un sujet sur
lequel il nous faudra poursuivre les
discussions tout en gardant à l'esprit
qui ne doit jamais compromettre nos
opérations ou entraîner une menace pour
la sécurité de nos agents sur le terrain
auquel je tiens ici à rendre aussi un
hommage tout particulier là aussi dans
le cadre de la DPR la délégation pour le
renseignement parlementaire pour le
renseignement avec les présidents
houliers et gassidou je crois que nous
avons trouvé un terrain de travail assez
inédit sous la Cinquième République
dans le cadre de l'économie de guerre
nous n'échapperons pas à travailler
collectivement sur le financement des
entreprises de la base industrielle et
technologique de défense mais je pense
aussi en particulier à nos PME à nos ETI
le Parlement c'est largement emparé de
ce sujet vous avez relayé les
préoccupations qui venaient du terrain
et nous devront poursuivre de manière
très concrète ces différentes réflexions
sur les sujets liés aux ressources
humaines vous avez été nombreux à
revenir sur les enjeux de fidélisation
aux travaux sur la grille indiciaire ou
sur les enjeux indemnitaires recrutement
des militaires d'actifs mais aussi sur
le modèle que nous entendons atteindre
en matière de réserve là aussi tout est
tard d'exécution il nous faudra
évidemment revenir devant le Parlement
dans vos missions de contrôle et puis je
pense enfin à la remonter en puissance
de nos armées dans nos outre-mer en
particulier de là où je viens je voulais
le reciter de nouveau ici à cette
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale pour
assurer demain notre souveraineté bien
au-delà de l'Hexagone nous le devons à
nos concitoyens
ultramarin nous la devons à tout à
chacun mesdames et messieurs les députés
pour conclure je fais enfin vous dire
l'honneur qui fut le mien de défendre ce
projet de loi de programmation militaire
devant vous moi qui est comme votre
rapporteur portez l'uniforme en d'autres
temps humblement respectueusement en
écoutant et en répondant aux arguments
qui ont été développés par chaque groupe
politique représenté sur ces bancs tels
que les Français l'ont décidé lors des
dernières élections législatives je
crois qu'en ce livrant à cet exercice
démocratique respectueux nous avons
chacun permis de renforcer le projet de
défense que nous portons pour la nation
nous avons livré aux femmes et aux
hommes qui servent au quotidien sous
l'uniforme et plus largement à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens un débat à
la hauteur des défis qu'ils auront à
relever demain pour notre sécurité
collective et pour notre souveraineté
sans oublier que ces décisions
s'inscrivent dans nos traditions en lien
avec notre mémoire nationale madame la
ministre et le lien qui unit des armées
d'aujourd'hui avec nos anciens
combattants tout comme avec notre
jeunesse plus encore nous avons fait la
démonstration que le débat démocratique
le débat parlementaire de qualité et la
solution qui permet à une nation de
s'armer face aux menaces qu'il a vise
quand tant de nos compétiteurs ventes
trop facilement et trop simplement les
mérites de modèles autoritaire je forme
le vœu que ce combat des idées qui fait
la force de notre République qui a
permis d'aboutir sur ce texte qui vous
est soumis désormais au vote féconde
pour les 7 prochaines années et pour
longtemps encore le succès de nos armes
et la grandeur de la France je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
avant de débuter la discussion générale
je rappelle pour le respect des orateurs
que si des collègues ont des appels
urgent à passer je les invite à sortir
de l'hémicycle et pour ceux qui ont des
oreillettes n'imaginez pas que parce que
vous mettez la main devant votre bouche
qu'on ne vous voit pas
j'ouvre la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur Fabien Roussel pour le
groupe gauche-démocrate et républicaine
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
augmenter le budget des armées garantir
la défense et la sécurité de notre pays
oui mille fois oui
mais doubler ce budget et le porter à
413 milliards d'euros 1000 fois non
cette loi de programmation militaire
s'inscrit dans une course aux armements
particulièrement inquiétantes
inquiétante puisque les dépenses
militaires au niveau mondial ont elles
aussi atteint un record en 2022 avec
2240 milliards de dollars une somme
historique alors oui il y a de quoi être
très inquiet face à cette économie de
guerre qui se généralise synonyme au
fond de défaitisme et de course à la
guerre vous dites qu'il faut avoir une
guerre d'avance au risque d'avoir une
paix de retard bien sûr nous devons
protéger nos concitoyens ou qu'ils se
trouvent dans l'Hexagone comme en
Polynésie aux Antilles en Guyane ou dans
l'océan Indien
cette exigence nous l'avons dit n'est
pas négociable tout comme est impérative
la défense de nos zones économiques
exclusives la lutte contre les attaques
cybers le développement du renseignement
ou encore la préservation de l'espace de
toute militarisation mais face à ces
défis une question simple se pose avant
nous les moyens de tout faire monsieur
le ministre avant nous les moyens de
financer à la fois une armée de défense
nationale et une armée de projections
extérieure avec un porte-avions nouvelle
génération de financer la dissuasion
nucléaire à ce point tout cela au
service d'une stratégie militaire placée
sous la direction de l'OTAN nous ne le
pensons pas c'est tellement vrai que
malgré les sommes considérables engagées
les cibles de plusieurs grands
programmes d'équipements ne sont pas
atteintes des blindés des rafales des
frégates et des drones notamment
manquent à l'appel
l'indépendance de notre défense la
sécurité de nos intérêts nationaux
peuvent être mises en péril au profit
d'opérations extérieures qu'elles soient
menées seules ou au sein d'alliance
d'ailleurs d'autant que depuis 20 ans
les guerres expéditionnèrent menées en
Libye en Afghanistan ou Sahel non réglé
aucun des problèmes qui étaient posés
sans que la bravoure d'ailleurs le
professionnalisme exemplaire de nos
soldats soient en cause naturellement et
je tiens à saluer de nouveau la mémoire
de celles et ceux qui ont laissé la vie
dans ces combats
mais il est temps aujourd'hui d'en finir
avec ce modèle d'un autre siècle le
modèle que vous présentez décrit comme
celui d'une armée complète étant réalité
une illusion que des militaires ont
d'ailleurs qualifié eux-mêmes d'armée
Banzaï tant les manques dans certains
secteurs sont criant et je ne parle pas
seulement des munitions la justification
c'est bien sûr la dissuasion nucléaire
dont le poids n'a jamais été au ciel
élevé je le redis ici Monsieur le
Ministre tant qu'il n'y aura pas de
désengagement de toutes les puissances
nucléaires oui les communistes le disent
la dissuasion nucléaire restera la clé
de voûte de notre politique de défense
dont acte mais mais il consacrait 54
milliards d'euros par an
durant cette LPM soit 22 millions 22
millions d'euros par jour
s'étaler bien au-delà de l'entretien de
notre arsenal nous ne sommes pas les
seuls à nous questionner sur de telles
dépenses et d'ailleurs
à titre équivalent un ancien membre du
Conseil de sécurité nationale sous
Barack Obama déplorer voici quelques
jours je le cite que le Pentagone lui
aussi dépense beaucoup d'argent dans les
armes nucléaires les chasseurs de 5e
génération les sous-marins alors que ce
fait sentir un simple mais indispensable
besoin de production d'artillerie enfin
nous regrettons l'absence d'une
véritable d'un véritable secteur public
en matière d'industrie de défense
s'appuyant sur des entreprises publiques
et sur les compétences de nos ingénieurs
de nos chercheurs et des ouvriers d'État
faute de cela le financement de notre
industrie de défense dépend
malheureusement de ses ventes d'armes et
de l'export
alors comme nos collègues communistes au
Sénat nous estimons nous aussi que les
choix portés par cette loi de
programmation militaire ne sont pas les
bons pour notre pays la défense de ses
intérêts alors notre groupe se félicite
de quelques avancées comme ce premier
pas vers un contrôle parlementaire de
nos exportations d'armement l'extension
résistant étrangers de la mention mort
pour la France merci madame la ministre
et l'entrée au panthéon de Missak
Manouchian mais tout cela reste bien
insuffisant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle malgré quelques avancées
notables pour nos armées malgré monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président de la Commission
malgré la qualité de nos débats la
disponibilité de Monsieur ministre pour
apporter toutes les réponses aux
questions que nous avons posées
les députés communistes et les députés
du groupe GDR votre rencontre ce texte
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Laurent Pagny fous pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire
madame la présidente madame monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues sur la loi de
programmation militaire le groupe yote
salut le compromis trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire ce pacte avec nos armées
traduit l'engagement sans faille des
parlementaires je tiens dès à présent à
rendre hommage à nos militaires qui
assurent au quotidien la défense de
notre territoire national et de notre
sécurité collective depuis le début de
ce texte en avril dernier jusqu'à son
adoption en première lecture à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat je crois que
tous ici nous pouvons reconnaître que
nos débats ont été à la hauteur des
enjeux et de l'engagement des militaires
l'ensemble des groupes tant de la
majorité que de l'opposition ont apporté
leur pierre à l'édifice et ont
contribuer à améliorer ce texte qui
engagera la nation pour des décennies
bien au-delà du seul horizon 2030 on
peut ajuste titre se réjouir de cet
accord trouvé à la veille du 14 juillet
en CMP les parlementaires ont obtenu de
réels avancées pour nos armées celles
qui retient toute notre attention est
évidemment l'amélioration de la
trajectoire budgétaire en accélérant le
rythme de la hausse de notre budget
défense nous envoyant un signal nous
envoyons un signal fort à l'ensemble de
nos partenaires sur la scène
internationale alors que le texte
initial renvoyait les efforts les plus
lourds à l'après présidentielle de 2027
la CMP a fait le choix de renforcer le
déploiement des crédits dès 2024 avec
une première tranche une première marche
à 3,3 milliards d'euros notre groupe
soutient fermement cette évolution
dans le même sens notre groupe avait
également plaidé pour consacrer dans la
loi les décaissements annuels des
ressources extra budgétaires nous
saluons le choix de la CMP d'inscrire
explicitement cette prévision dans un
tableau dédié
autre sujet non moins important les
liens du Parlement avec nos armées cette
loi de programmation militaire et
l'occasion pour le Parlement de se
saisir pleinement de notre défense
nationale cette loi renforce
indéniablement le rôle et la place des
parlementaires je souligne la conquête
de la CMP sur l'article 7 qui prévoit
enfin une véritable actualisation à
mi-parcours de cette programmation via
une loi dédiée avant la fin de l'année
2027 face aux enjeux il était essentiel
de graver dans le marbre cette clause de
revoyure notre groupe salut aussi le
renforcement des pouvoirs d'évaluation
du Parlement en particulier le pouvoir
de contrôle des commissaires de la
Défense nationale sur l'exécution de la
loi de programmation militaire
la commission mixte paritaire est allée
encore plus loin en actant la création
d'une commission parlementaire sur les
exportations d'armes c'est une avancée
historique pour le Parlement
parmi toutes ces avancées notre groupe a
tout de même un regret le Sénat avait
adopté un livret d'épargne souveraineté
afin de financer les entreprises de
notre BITD nous savons tous à quel point
l'accès aux financement bancaire est
difficile pour les entreprises de ce
secteur les parlementaires alertent
Bercy sur ce sujet depuis plusieurs
années ce choix audacieux n'a pas
survécu à l'opposition du ministère de
l'Économie ces regrettables certes la
commission mixte paritaire a retenu le
fléchage d'une partie de l'épargne du
livret A cela va dans le bon sens mais
je rappelle que les fonds du livret A
servent avant tout au financement du
logement social il ne faudrait pas que
ce financement soit diminué et en
particulier dans le contexte actuel
enfin je terminerai en insistant sur un
point qui est parfois laissé de côté il
est vrai que lorsqu'on fait défiler les
milliards les livraisons de char les
munitions on peut parfois oublier les
conditions de vie de nos soldats c'est
pourtant une priorité de cette
programmation assuré une qualité de vie
aux militaire mais aussi à leur famille
notre groupe liotte a beaucoup œuvré
pour faire inscrire les ambitions du
plan famille dans cette loi de
programmation militaire ce plan est très
attendu sur le terrain et je salue le
choix fait par ce texte et son rapport
annexé de renforcer l'implication des
collectivités et des élocaux dans sa
mise en oeuvre vous l'aurez compris
madame monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur mes
chers collègues le groupe Eliot votera
cette loi de programmation militaire je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame a une gente pour le groupe
Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur chers
collègues
au soldats tombés ou blessés pour notre
drapeau à leurs frères d'armes qui
s'engage pour la France aux personnes
civiles de la défense aux forces morales
familles et réservistes qui les
soutiennent je voudrais s'exprimer notre
reconnaissance l'histoire nous rappelle
que c'est bien sur leur courage que ça
puis aujourd'hui notre démocratie et que
leur combat passé est présent nous
permet de nous tenir ici libre
chers collègues nous le martelons depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines cette loi
de programmation militaire est une loi
de remonter en puissance une loi de
souveraineté une loi d'autonomie
stratégique elle répond à une
appréciation que je crois commune et
partagée sur nos bancs
sécurité pardon qui se dégrade qu'il
s'agisse de la guerre en Ukraine de
l'élargissement des champs de
confrontation ou encore des ruptures
technologiques et donc une moindre
remontée en puissance d'abord par la
vision et l'ambition qu'elle porte pour
la France notre majorité avait stoppé
l'érosion de nos forces armées du budget
nos forces armées répond aujourd'hui
avec cette loi à des besoins de 413
milliards d'euros dans le respect des
contraintes budgétaires nationales que
nous connaissons entre 2017 et 2030 le
budget annuel des armées aura ainsi plus
que doublé et cette trajectoire
permettra la France de tenir et son rang
et ses engagements ils permettra à la
France d'être une alliée crédible et
exemplaire dans l'espace roi atlantique
il permettra à la France d'être un
moteur du renforcement du pilier
européens de l'Alliance mais aussi
d'être un partenaire lucide et
pourvoyeur de sécurité à haute valeur
ajoutée c'est ensuite une loi de
souveraineté nos fondamentaux seront
ainsi consolidés qu'il s'agisse de la
crédibilité de la permanence de notre
dissuasion nucléaire clé de vous de
notre défense qu'il s'agisse de notre
ambition de doubler la réserve
opérationnelle qu'il s'agit encore de la
défense de nos territoires ultramarés de
notre zone économique exclusive la
deuxième au monde je le rappelle et
l'exercice Pégase 23 qui est une
projection de notre puissance au plus
près de nos territoires de
l'indopacifiques et qui se déroule
actuellement illustre déjà cet effort
conséquent enfin c'est une loi
d'autonomie stratégique c'est-à-dire une
loi de capacité d'appréciation de
décision et d'action souveraines des
moyens inédits seront alloués aussi
Berre à l'espace au drone au
renseignements c'est une autonomie
stratégique qui va de pair avec une
économie de guerre qui nous permet donc
de sécuriser nos approvisionnements
stratégiques de constituer pardon des
stocks stratégiques des
approvisionnements critiques pardon te
constituer des stocks stratégiques ou
encore de relocaliser sur le territoire
national et en Europe des filières de
production enfin cette loi consolide
également le financement de notre base
industrielle et technologique de défense
et plus particulièrement de nos PME
innovantes celles-ci ont besoin d'un
engagement fort de l'État à leur côté
mais monsieur ministre madame la
ministre sans doute faudra-t-il aller un
peu plus loin je voudrais donner pour
exemple la société un Antoine moteur qui
est un exemple concret de PME innovante
et qui a besoin d'un soutien important
maintenant peint dans un an chers
collègues les débats parlementaires ont
enrichi la copie présentée par le
gouvernement et au nombre des avancées
portées par notre groupe Renaissance je
voudrais citer par exemple notre demande
d'études complémentaire sur le format de
porte-avions qui a été entendu également
aux côtés de notre collègue Yannick
chenvar notre groupe s'est mobilisé pour
une politique de rémunération des
militaires plus attractive et plus
progressive et puis nous avons également
porté une attention particulière à
l'insertion professionnelle des
conjoints et puis c'est ils sont mix
paritaires que députés sénateurs
ensemble nous nous sommes entendus sur
jordinité deux points importants
l'accélération tout d'abord des marches
budgétaires cela a déjà été évoquée en
début de période au service du
renforcement de l'entraînement de nos
forces armées et puis le renforcement de
notre Parlement par la création d'une
commission parlementaire d'évaluation de
la politique du gouvernement en matière
d'exportation d'armement et pourtant la
voix de mon groupe je souhaiterais tout
particulièrement remercier notre
ministre pour sa grande écoute et sa
grande disponibilité le président de
notre commission et notre rapporteur
pour leur travail et leurs éclairages
ainsi que tous les parlementaires sur
tous les bancs ils se sont emparés nous
sommes en paillés ensemble des enjeux
avec exigences je crois nous avons porté
haut la qualité des débats et nous avons
ce je crois honneur à notre assemblée
chers collègues il appartient désormais
aux assemblées de se prononcer
définitivement sur ce texte et au
rendez-vous donné par les Français pour
leur sécurité et leur défense nationale
le groupe n'est Renaissance dépendra
présent nous voterons donc pour cette
loi de transformation pour notre
sécurité notre liberté et notre
souveraineté pour notre engagement en
tant qu'allié exemplaire et fiable de
haut niveau nous voterons pour une
France puissante influente solidaire
partenaire de souveraineté je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
la parole est à Monsieur Franck Giletti
pour le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur dans
deux jours la France honorera ses armées
à l'occasion de notre fête nationale à
Paris comme d'autres territoires et bien
sûr le Var dont je suis élu premier
département militaire de France et qui
accueille le plus grand port militaire
d'Europe des défilés permettront à nos
concitoyens de redécouvrir un monde
militaire parfois méconnu mais à qui
nous devons tant nous pouvons tous être
fier de nos armées
héritières de l'histoire multicellulaire
de notre pays et qui continue à faire
face au défi de notre temps hélas de
plus en plus conflictuel les ambitions
territoriales de certaines puissances
étrangères le retour de la guerre sur le
sol européen ou la montée de nouvelles
menaces dans de nouveaux champs et
domaines comme l'espace ou le cyber
constitue autant d'enjeux face auxquels
la France doit tenir son rang au
rassemblant national nous considérons
que ce serait méconnaître nos armées que
de nier leur singularité la France
dispose d'un modèle embryonnaire sur
certains segments mais encore complet
chapeauté par la dissuasion et fort du
dévouement de 260 000 personnels
militaires et civils c'est par respect
pour ces hommes et ces femmes
exceptionnelles que nous avons veillées
en tant que premier groupe d'oppositions
avoir une attitude responsable tout au
long des débats soyons clairs cette LPM
est-elle parfaite évidemment non des
programmes d'armement sont décalés dans
le temps des armes et des segments sont
en souffrance je pense à l'artillerie
qui manque de feu de radar je pense à la
longue portée avec le manque de léru
tandis que la session annoncée de
missile scalp à l'Ukraine grève nos
capacités à frapper dans la profondeur
je pense aussi à la réduction de la
cible sur les avions de chasse passant
de 185 à 137 rafales cet LPM a-t-elle
les moyens de ses ambitions l'effort
financier là malgré les contraintes
posées par votre chef de gouvernement
a-t-on oublié à Matignon la nécessité de
contrer les effets de l'inflation et de
combler les retards de paiement
accumulés depuis des années ce n'est pas
tant le budget total de 400 milliards
d'euros avec 13 autres milliards à
sincériser que nous dénoncions au groupe
ration nationale mais plutôt la
ventilation entre les marches
de ce point de vue le compromis trouvé
en CMP même s'il ne correspond pas tout
à fait à nos propositions va dans le bon
sens nous notons néanmoins avec quelle
énergie le gouvernement a défendu un
effort budgétaire reposant pour
l'essentiel sur ses successeurs merci
pour ce signe de confiance monsieur le
ministre cette LPM est-elle cohérente
malgré les indéniables failles capacité
à mentionner il ne saurait être question
de jeter aux orties la copie rendue par
le service par les services du ministère
des armées à cet égard j'aimerais
remercier tous ceux qui ont travaillé à
l'élaboration de ce texte et surtout
réaffirmer la reconnaissance que mon
groupe porte à nos trois armes et
dévouées alors direction et services à
nos personnels civils de la défense
ainsi qu'aux fleurons de l'industrie de
défense française pour être clair donc
cette LPM permettra au rassemblement
national et à sa présidente de mener la
politique de défense quelle ambitionne
quand elle sera présidente
nous vous alertons cependant monsieur le
ministre sur des enjeux qui demeurent
essentiels nos armées ont besoin de
carburant dès maintenant pour faire
rouler leurs chars et faire rouler leurs
avions elles ont besoin dès maintenant
de munitions pour tirer avec leurs armes
en clair il faut du pouvoir d'achat dès
les premières marches nous industriels
sont parfaitement capables de répondre à
leurs besoins et d'apporter la plupart
du temps des solutions souveraines dès
lors qu'ils sont soutenus par l'État
cela implique de renoncer des programmes
voués à l'échec comme le Scaff ou la
mgcs autre enjeu majeur le recrutement
et la fidélisation comment peut-on
continuer à recruter entraîner fidéliser
des pilotes de chasse pour lequel il est
prévu que 147 heures de vol cette année
contre les 180 minimum Rocky par énorme
autant fidèle à notre programme
présidentiel c'est en ce sens que nous
avons souhaité amender le projet de loi
tout au long de son examen nous nous
félicitons du fait que certaines de nos
propositions étaient reprises sur le cas
de lancement des marches nous l'avons
dit mais aussi sur le livret de
souveraineté directement inspiré par le
fond souverain français au cœur de notre
programme à l'heure de voter il faut
donc prendre ses responsabilités
responsabilité un mot qui a visiblement
manqué au gouvernement de droite comme
de gauche qui ont successivement
affaibli nos armées en les privant de
leurs moyens alloué à d'autres
politiques dont on mesure aujourd'hui à
contrario les effets déplorables l'air
GPP en étant exemple il faut réparer nos
armées c'est une ardente obligation
elles sont sollicitées au-delà de leurs
moyens et de leur contrat opérationnel
les objectifs opérationnels que vous
présentez monsieur le ministre sont
d'ailleurs supérieurs à ceux du Livre
blanc de 2013 alors que le format de nos
armées n'a pas évolué en conséquence en
témoigne le groupe aéronaval mobilisable
environ 40 à 50% du temps d'où l'urgence
d'un nouveau porte-avions et le déni
d'une extrême gauche irresponsable les
retours d'expérience sur l'exercice
Orion nous indiquent par ailleurs qui a
décidément urgence à agir en termes de
flux de capacité satellitaires et même
des cubes de base
nous devons donc à nous armer un soutien
plein et entier et c'est bien sur ce
point que nous sommes fiers de nous
distinguer d'une partie de cette
hémicycle pour laquelle les intérêts de
la France et des Français ne sont pas
une priorité
alors faisons honneur à nos militaires
œuvront pour leur garantir les moyens de
leur ambition en votant cette LPM
veillons au succès des armes de la
France la nation avant tout
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Bastien Lachaud
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
présidente ministre collègue
si nous projetons notre regard hors de
nos frontières
ne pas mesurer le poids des rivalités
d'intérêts et les risques que font peser
sur la paix de multiples affrontements
la France aura à dire avec force qui ne
saurait y avoir de véritables
communautés internationales tant que les
deux tiers de la planète continueront
d'échanger leurs hommes et leurs biens
contre la fin et le mépris une France
juste et solidaire qui entend vivre en
paix avec tous peut éclairer la marge de
l'humanité à cette fin elle doit d'abord
compter sur elle-même
ainsi s'exprimer le président Mitterrand
le jour de son investiture le 21 mai
1981 depuis tout s'est aggravé et vous
n'en avez pas pris la mesure
la terrible invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie le bouleversement climatique les
crises financières provoquées par le
capitalisme devrait être le moment d'une
telle prise de conscience la nécessité
d'une France indépendante pour défendre
la paix faire face aux catastrophes
climatiques et garantir notre
souveraineté
il fallait permettre à la nation tout
entière de s'unir derrière cet objectif
vous ne lui en avez pas donné les moyens
aucun débat digne de ce nom une vis
érable revue nationale stratégique
bâclée notre pays relégué au rang
d'allier exemplaire de l'Alliance
atlantique
caricature des caricatures vous nous
avez refusé un livre blanc que la loi
appelle maintenant de ses vœux
cette EPM devait être une loi d'urgence
pour se préparer à un engagement majeur
mais il a fallu attendre l'intervention
du Parlement pour que les marges que
vous nous proposiez ne soit pas
inflation déduite inférieure à celle que
nous avions programmé en 2018 maintenant
ce sont les mêmes
au final vous suivez le mouvement
général et militariser les nouvelles
frontières de l'humanité il était temps
d'agir dans ces domaines nous vous le
disions depuis des années mais vous
refusez en parallèle d'agir pour un
traité de démilitarisation de l'espace
ou pour un droit international cyber
vous refusez donc de vrai pour la paix
c'est une occasion manquée
cette loi de programmation militaire
aurait dû permettre d'anticiper les
crises induite par le bouleversement
climatique et préparer la préétrole il
n'en n'a rien été vous avez balayé d'un
revers de main tous nos amendements
pourtant de bon sens vous avez même
refusé que la France propose la création
d'une force internationale de réponse
catastrophe climatique c'est une
occasion manquée
cette LPM pouvait garantir
l'indépendance de notre nation vous
n'avez cessé d'invoquer la souveraineté
pour mieux la brader la loi n'est même
pas probulguée et nous venons
d'apprendre que l'opérateur dci passera
sous pavillon canadien c'est donc cela
la souveraineté à vos yeux encourager la
vente de nos entreprises à des fonds
étrangers
vous pouviez pourtant proposer une loi
de planification et de protection de la
souveraineté une fois de plus c'est une
occasion banquier
si nous avons pu obtenir quelques
victoires la sécurisation des budgets de
développement du successeur du Tigre et
d'un avion spatial l'augmentation de 400
millions des besoins programmés pour le
renseignement la préservation de la
militarité des services de renseignement
un rapport sur le bilan de la
réintégration du commandement intégré au
sein de l'OTAN la filière souveraine de
drones et de robot sous-marins ou encore
le privilège une solution souveraine
pour le drone aérien de la marine nous
ne pourrons voter ce texte qui manque
cruellement d'ambition ne répond pas aux
enjeux immenses qui nous attendent et
qui constitue au final une occasion
manquée rendez-vous donc lors des
différents débats budgétaires pour
réellement donner aux armes de la France
aux femmes et aux hommes qui les servent
les moyens de défendre la paix et la
patrie
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
Thieriot pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président de la
Commission défense mes chers collègues
avec cette CMP conclusive mission
accomplie mission accomplie pour les
âmes de la France mission accomplie pour
donner à ceux qui les servent les moyens
qu'il méritent mission accomplie pour la
sécurité des Français depuis le début de
cette mandature rarement l'occasion nous
a été donnée d'être fier de ce qui se
passait dans cette hémicycle les apôtres
de la subversion nous ayant généralement
privé de débats démocratique serein sur
ce texte je tiens à saluer la retenue de
chacun le travail de monsieur le
rapporteur la volonté d'aboutir de la
CMP et l'écoute du ministre qui a su
retenir le meilleur de ce que chacun
apportait chacun a fait un pas vers
l'autre et c'est comme cela qu'on avance
sans doute parce que la matière est de
celle qui engagent et qui oblige elle
touche à la vie et à la mort de celles
et de ceux qui portent l'uniforme elle
touche à la vie et à la mort de la
nation au nom de notre groupe trois
avancées majeures justifient une
légitime fierté les avancées sur le
cadencement des marches les avancées sur
la cohérence les avancées sur le soutien
à notre industrie de défense les
avancées sur les marches ici à
l'Assemblée mes chers collègues vous
aviez voté la sécurisation des Rex à
hauteur de 13 milliards et la garantie
que les budgets établis soient des
planchers c'était une avancée nous
avions souligné qu'il y avait dans cette
lettre LPM une certaine dissonance le
plus gros démarche était reporté après
les échéances électorales de 2027 grâce
au travail des sénateurs de notre groupe
au Sénat nous avons trouvé un point
d'accord avec 2,3 milliards de plus pour
nos armées jusqu'en 2027 dans les
tumulte du monde la France hausse la
garde et est en rendez-vous de
l'Histoire merci monsieur le ministre
aussi car ces avancées renforcent la
cohérence de notre modèle d'armée une
LPM c'est un subtile assemblage pas des
cases à cocher pour mettre des véhicules
dans des hangars ces 2,3 milliards iront
prioritairement au programme 178 à
l'entraînement de nos forces et au MCO
la robustesse d'une armée son agilité se
mesure en déploiement sur le terrain en
France ou chez nos alliés en heure de
vol ou en jour de maire j'ai en tête un
peloton de cantique cavalerie déployé en
Estonie dans le cadre du dispositif lynx
qui ne pouvait être commandé à la vue
par le chef de détachement car il
voulait laisser les heures de potentiel
moteur à ses équipages demain cela se
produira moins c'est un gage
d'efficacité c'est aussi une manière de
contribuer à l'attractivité du métier
des armes car c'est de cela dont rêve
ceux qui ont choisi de l'embrasser
enfin quelle légitime fierté nous tirons
de l'accent qui a été mis sur le
financement de la BITD ces 4000
entreprises et ses 200.000 salariés qui
dans la touffeur des usines où les sales
blanches et laboratoires baptistes notre
outil de défense nous avions voté la
création d'un médiateur du crédit
d'efforts nos collègues sénateurs ont
introduit le fléchage d'une partie de
l'épargne réglementée vers l'industrie
de défense avec la volonté d'aller plus
loin par l'institution d'un livret
résilience et souveraineté en 2026 si
les résultats ne sont pas à la hauteur
des promesses c'est un message majeur
qui fait suite aux différentes missions
parlementaires qui ont été conduites par
moi-même ma collègue balai bleue notre
collègue placard ou le sénateur à
l'isard malgré le déni des acteurs
financiers de la plaque qui invoque les
encours globaux et non le financement
par strat il y a bien des difficultés
pour les PME qu'il agissent du
financement bancaire classique du
financement export ou du haut de bilan
la DGA la souligné le ministre l'a
rappelé notre Assemblée a mis un terme à
ce rideau de fumée qui use de la
globalité des chiffres pour masquer la
vérité des faits les textes sont votés
nous serons là pour rappeler que les
dirigeants des grandes banques qui dans
d'autres secteurs Renta la France des
services signalés n'ont pas à se laisser
dicter leur politique d'investissement
par des services de compliance souvent
sous l'influence de certaines ONG qui
par idéalisent ou complaisance coupable
se font les alliés objectifs de nos
compétiteurs stratégiques l'argent n'a
pas d'odeur mais les banques ont un
drapeau nous serons là pour le rappeler
cette loi n'est pas parfaite mais elle
répond à la menace elle respecte nos
soldats nous veillerons à être les
aiguillons vigilants de son exécution en
attendant nous voterons ce texte de
concorde nation al merci monsieur le
député
mes chers collègues je vous informe que
sur le vote du projet de loi tel qui
suit de la CMP je suis saisi par le
groupe Renaissance et le groupe
démocrate d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'ensemble de l'Assemblée nationale la
parole est à Madame
Josy pardon Puerto pour le groupe
démocrate modem et indépendant
[Applaudissements]
merci mais je vais prendre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de commission cher Thomas
madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues l'objectif était fixé et
grâce aux efforts de tous nous y voilà à
deux jours du 14 juillet nous nous
apprêtons à adopter un budget historique
pour nos armées 413 milliards d'euros le
plus important depuis la fin de la
guerre froide je souhaiterais ici
remercier notre ministre pour son
engagement et disponibilité nos
rapporteur le président
ainsi que l'ensemble de nos collègues
membres de la commission défense ou non
qui se sont impliqués sur ce texte pour
l'enrichir et faire vivre le débat le
Parlement aura su rappeler qu'en matière
de défense les discussions politiques
doivent aussi se tenir pour confirmer
les choix stratégiques et les
orientations de la nation je tiens en ce
sens à remercier également nos deux
rapporteurs et nos deux rapporteurs et
nos rapporteurs pour avis le travail
accomplie dans cette assemblée comme au
Sénat permet de mieux prendre en compte
toutes les diversités de nos armées
leurs besoins sans oublier le cyber les
réservistes ou les questions mémorielles
qui vous le savez sont des sujets qui
tiennent à cœur à mon groupe bien que de
nombreux points se soient révélés
sensuels la question du budget et
notamment les marches constituées plus
l'examen dans cette de l'examen dans
cette mission un point de tension pour
lequel il me semble que nous avons
trouvé un compromis raisonnable je tiens
à rappeler chers collègues qu'en
augmentant le budget des armées de plus
de 40%, c'est un effort important que
nous demandons à nos concitoyens dans
des temps où les troubles géopolitiques
leur apparaissent au moins aussi
important que les difficultés
économiques
aussi si les deux trois les deux
milliards 3 d'euros supplémentaires
seront les bienvenus pour assurer
l'entraînement et le maintien en
condition opérationnelle cet effort doit
surtout s'inscrire dans le cadre du
recensement des besoins effectués par
les états majors permettant que nos
besoins matériels correspondent à nos
capacités humaines nous avons entendu
ici et là que la France devrait se doter
de force bien plus importantes pour
protéger son territoire et ses
ressortissants à l'image de certains
pays qui voient revenir la guerre à leur
porte je crois cependant qu'après le
débat public qui s'est tenu sur cette
question dans notre pays nous pouvons
partager le constat que nos armées
profiteront de cette loi de
programmation militaire pour enclencher
des transformations plus que nécessaire
pour demeurer une puissance du 21e
siècle oui cette LPM est nécessaire pour
moderniser nos armées et leur permettre
de s'adapter aux nouvelles menaces et
aux nouveaux espaces de conflictualité
avec ce budget que nous allons voter
nous investirons dans l'Inno et de
renseignements nous renouvellerons nos
capacités spatiales d'écoute et
d'observation nous allons nous doter des
drones et des robots dont nous manquions
nous allons également poursuivre le
développement de notre cyberdéfense
devenu un enjeu de premier plan et
accentuer nos efforts sur la lutte
informatique d'influence tous ces
investissements nous permettront enfin
de renforcer notre capacité à contrer
les stratégies hybrides bien évidemment
nous avons tenu à rappeler que dans le
monde de plus en plus complexe qui se
prépare la France n'était pas seule nos
coopérations avec nos partenaires sont
essentiels avec l'OTAN bien sûr et nous
nous réjouissons de l'entrée prochaine
de la Suède mais également avec l'Union
européenne qui est amenée à devenir un
acteur clé de notre stratégie notamment
en matière industrielle et mon groupe
formule le veut que les élections à
venir renforceront notre rôle dans ce
domaine
par cette loi de programmation militaire
nous améliorons également l'insécurité
de nos systèmes d'information je tiens
ici à saluer ma collègue Sabine qu'il
aille pour son travail de rapporteur sur
ce sujet le texte nous permet en effet
de renforcer les prérogatives de Lancy
d'assurer une meilleure coopération
entre les acteurs de l'écosystème tout
en nous adaptant aux évolutions
techniques et technologiques de la
menace enfin je me réjouis qu'une partie
de cette LPM soit consacrée aux familles
des militaires et aux militaires blessés
en service nous sommes très
reconnaissants de leur engagement au
service de la nation et nous devons les
accompagner en cas de blessure nous
avons donc décidé de renforcer le régime
d'indemnisation des militaires blessés
en service je salue également le plan
blessé présenté par Patricia mirales qui
permettra de simplifier les démarches et
de renforcer l'accompagnement des
blessés dans la durée nous n'oublions
pas les familles de militaires qui
acceptent elles aussi les conséquences
de l'engagement opérationnel grâce au
plan familier 2 nous allons renforcer
l'accompagnement des militaires dans la
recherche de logement d'emploi d'école
ou encore de crèches pour toutes ces
raisons cette loi de programmation
militaire nous semble particulièrement
importante pour engager la
transformation de nos armées et pour la
défense de notre nation le groupe
démocrate voteront donc en faveur de ce
texte historique je vous remercie
merci madame la députée
mes chers collègues il reste trois
orateurs avant le vote je vous invite à
être attentif merci la parole est à
Madame anapick pour le groupe socialiste
et à parenté
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames messieurs plutôt les
rapporteurs
chers collègues ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 2030 et finalement un très bon
exemple du parlementarisme de fait qui
est imposé au gouvernement par les
rapports de force politique à l'oeuvre
au Parlement
lorsque le pouvoir exécutif fait le
choix de ne pas utiliser toutes les
ficelles réglementaires et où
constitutionnelles et je vous en
remercie monsieur le ministre sa
disposition pour contraindre le
Parlement le voilà obligé de reconnaître
sa majorité toute relative de trouver un
compromis avec les autres forces
politiques en présence
au groupe socialiste et apparenté nous
nous en réjouissons non pas parce que
cela serait la marque d'une quelconque
faiblesse gouvernementale mais parce
qu'en fin les parlementaires de
l'opposition sont amenés à être
considérés dans l'élaboration de la loi
ce qui ne va pas de soi sous la 5e
République
à l'occasion de son examen en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale nous
vous avions fait part de nos inquiétudes
quant à la crédibilité de votre texte et
nous avions souligné ces insuffisances
tel était le cas notamment de l'absence
pour la deuxième fois consécutive d'un
livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité nationale document pourtant
indispensable à la participation
effective de parlementaire et de
personnalités qualifiées à l'élaboration
de notre politique de défense de la
trajectoire budgétaire laquelle
reportait les principales Hauses de
crédit à l'après 2027 laissant ainsi la
place aux aléas politiques et
économiques comme en témoignent le
contexte inflationniste actuel de
l'absence de la possibilité de réviser
cette LPM au regard du contexte
international mouvant dans lequel nous
nous trouvons et du manque de mesure de
transparence relative notamment au
contrôle de l'action gouvernementale par
le Parlement suite à l'examen du texte
au Sénat puis en commission mixte
paritaire le parlementarisme de fait que
j'évoquais en introduction vous a obligé
à revoir votre copie grâce notamment au
travail résolu des socialistes du Sénat
nombre de propositions pourtant refuser
ici même en première lecture on finit
par être voté contre votre grès à la
Chambre haute puis accepter dans le
cadre des négociations en CMP la
trajectoire financière est désormais
modifiée avec des augmentations de
crédit plus linéaire et plus importante
dès le début de la programmation
l'actualisation de cette LPM devra
obligatoirement passer par le vote d'un
nouveau projet de loi et cette révision
interviendra en 2027 au plus tard la
future LPM poste 2030 devra être précédé
d'un livre blanc dont la commission
d'élaboration devra être mise en place
avant le 30 juin 2028
une commission parlementaire
d'évaluation de la politique du
gouvernement et des exportations du
gouvernement et des exportations
d'armement va également voir le jour
nous serons d'ailleurs particulièrement
vigilants quant aux modalités de sa mise
en œuvre néanmoins ces quelques
victoires qui finalement ne relèvent que
du bon sens ne nous empêche pas de
continuer à avoir certaines réserves sur
ce texte le modèle d'armée complet n'est
pas interrogé malgré l'argument
largement employé du retour de la haute
intensité sur le sol notre BITD ne
bénéficiera pas de la confiance dont
elle a besoin pour fonctionner
sereinement et qui aurait dû s'illustrer
par un engagement public ferme et de
long terme les craintes concernant notre
capacité à atteindre les standards
otaniens de préparation opérationnelle
ne sont pas tout à fait levés la faculté
de la France à être une nation cadre au
sein de ses alliances et sa capacité à
assurer un leadership auprès de ses
partenaires européens reste à démontrer
donc n'est assurément pas historique
comme cela nous a été répété à maintes
reprises lors des débats dans les faits
elle correspond davantage à une
actualisation de la présidence loi de
programmation elle ne constitue pas non
plus le vecteur de la modernisation tant
attendu par des armées laquelle est
désormais repoussée à un horizon post
2030 enfin elle ne correspond évidemment
pas plus à ce que nous aurions défendu
si nous avions été au pouvoir à votre
place malgré cela et même si vous ne
l'avez sans doute pas fait par
conviction force est de constater que
nos principales revendications ont été
entendus nous nous en félicitons et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voterons pour cette nouvelle mouture de
la programmation militaire je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée
chers collègues vu que vous discutez
tous entre vous je pense que vous
n'entendez pas le bruit de fond qui est
très désagréable et qui est un manque de
respect mes chers collègues pour
l'orateur qui est à la tribune donc
quand je vous demande de rester attentif
en fait c'est une manière polie de vous
demander de vous taire ou parler plus
doucement voilà je vous remercie
l'appareil la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Charles Larsonneur pour le groupe
horizon et apparenté
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs
monsieur madame la ministre mes chers
collègues à l'avant veille de notre fête
nationale et de ses traditionnelles
défilés et alors que nous arrivons au
terme de l'examen de ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire je voudrais
partager avec vous une fierté collective
oui nous pouvons être fiers mes chers
collègues fier d'abord de nos soldats
fiers de leur engagement pour la défense
de notre nation fier de leur combat pour
préserver chaque jour notre liberté nous
pouvons aussi être fiers du travail
parlementaire qui a été accompli par nos
deux chambres afin d'enrichir ce texte
d'une importance capitale pour nos
armées
ce travail a été je crois exigeant et de
bonnes tenues d'abord dans cette
assemblée nous avons pu ajouter de
nombreuses dispositions pour préciser
dans le rapport annexé les ambitions de
ce projet de loi pour les familles de
militaires pour l'environnement et pour
le financement de défense mais où nous
avons pu aussi poser la première pierre
d'un contre parlementaire soutenu sur
l'ensemble de la programmation le groupe
Horizon est apparenté a pris toute sa
part à ce travail transpartisan nous
nous félicitons des mesures qui ont été
conservées pour l'étude sur les
conditions de réalisation d'un second
porte-avion de nouvelles générations
pour la suppression de la durée minimale
en opération pour qu'une blessure ou une
maladie soit imputable au service ou
pour la protection et la sécurité de
données collectés par l'annecy ensuite
ce travail cette approfondie au Sénat
qui a fait le choix de renforcer le
contrôle parlementaire d'ajouter de
nouveaux outils pour le financement de
notre BITD et de rééquilibrer la
répartition annuelle de l'effort
budgétaire sur les premières années
les grands équilibres de ce budget ont
été préservés par la commission mix
paritaire sont bien distingués d'un côté
les besoins de la mission défense et de
l'autre les ressources extra budgétaires
ainsi que les marges frictionnelles et
les reports de charge nous pouvons
saluer ce choix de transparence voulu
par notre ministre des Armées ceci
renforce la sincérité de cette
programmation la copie qui en découlé
sérieuse cohérentes et complètes
sérieuses car elle prend toute la mesure
des changements géopolitiques la guerre
en Ukraine les tensions de
l'Indopacifique l'évolution de nos
partenariats en Afrique pour proposer de
nouvelles capacités d'action en
investissant plus et toujours mieux dans
les nouveaux champs de conflictualité
cohérente car elle confirme la montée en
puissance de notre modèle d'armée après
la réparation engagée par la précédente
LPM ce modèle c'est celui d'une armée
complète moderne capable d'intervenir
rapidement et en tant que nation cadre
dans de larges coalition épaulé soutenu
par une dissuasion nucléaire crédible
complète enfin car son ambition va
au-delà des lignes de compte de Lise
capacitaire pour renouveler un
engagement à hauteur d'homme ce projet
de loi ce sont aussi des grilles
indiciaires réhaussées un nouveau plan
pour les familles de militaires pour les
blessés de guerre ce sont des
investissements conséquents pour rénover
et construire des cadres de vie plus
simple pour de militaires et je voudrais
terminer mes chers collègues en
rappelant la portée internationale de ce
texte les impacts de ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire ne seront pas
seulement mesurés dans les murs de ce
Parlement ni au sein des seules
frontières de notre pays il est la
concrétisation opérationnelle de la
vision stratégique de la France nos
engagements stratégiques sont nombreux
au sein de l'Union européenne au sein de
l'OTAN en Afrique dans l'espace
Indo-Pacifique et partout où la France a
des ressortissants
c'est donc un message fort que nous
envoyons à nos alliés nous montrons que
la France donne les moyens de ses
ambitions et restera un partenaire
fiable à tous ceux qui voudraient
menacer notre souveraineté nous
réaffirmons notre rang de puissance
militaire majeure de ces deux moyens
d'action rapide et modernes et crédible
à nos compatriotes enfin ou qui se
trouvent sur le globe nous assurons une
protection et une sécurité toujours plus
forte alors oui c'est avec une très
grande fierté que le groupe horizon
votera en faveur de ce projet de loi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Cyrielle châtelain pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues samedi 24 juin et Jim et ses
hommes prennent le contrôle de Rostov
sur le don à 600 km de Moscou pendant
près de 24 heures personne ne sait ce
qu'ils veulent pendant 24 heures
personne ne sait jusqu'où ils iront et
quand il s'arrêteront et moi là je dois
vous l'avouer pendant ces 24 heures j'ai
imaginé un monde webgami perugine avait
le doigt sur le bouton rouge de la bombe
nucléaire le groupe Wagner est une bande
de mercenaires qui exécute sommairement
mutilé tortures les civils de butcha une
bande son poignée là qui ont mis en
scène et mis en ligne des vidéos de
décapitation de citoyens syriens une
milice qui en République centrafricaine
à Combrit de nombreux actes
d'intimidation des violences sexuelles
et des destructions d'habitation
imaginons ces hommes à la tête d'une
puissance dotée telle que la Russie
imaginons ces hommes avec le pouvoir
d'une arme d'année d'anéantissement
total nous voyons ici les limites de la
dissuasion nucléaire c'est pour cette
raison qu'avec nos collègues de la
France insoumise avec nos collègues
communistes nous avons porté la création
d'un commissariat à dissuasion nous
devons penser qu'elle sera la dissuasion
de demain car notre monde est en proie à
l'incertitude et à la stabilité alors
oui il faut évoluer oui il faut changer
alors que se tient aujourd'hui le sommet
de l'OTAN à Vilnius la question qui se
pose des sommes nous prêts sommes-nous
prêts à faire face à ce monde dans la
guerre de haute où les guerres de haute
intensité sont de nouveaux possibles et
où la guerre de l'information peut
déstabiliser un pays ainsi il est
évident que nos lois de programmation
militaires ne peuvent se limiter à
garantir le fonctionnement de nos armées
nous devons repenser notre modèle
d’armée pour faire face à ces menaces
nouvelles et multiformes pour assurer
une défense efficace nous ne pouvons pas
simplement additionner les euros nous
devons définir une vision stratégique
claire de nos défenses une vision qui
anticipe les conflits de demain par cet
LPM de continuité vous répondez
partiellement à ces questions légitimes
nous l'avons dit nous ne serons répondre
seul au conflit de demain il faut
construire dès à présent l'Europe de la
défense et nous déplorons toujours le
manque d'ambition de la France sur ce
sujet nous sommes heureux d'avoir pu
enrichir le rapport annexé sur cette
question mais force est de constater que
cette LPM n'apporte aucun renforcement
concret sur cette question deuxièmement
nous devons répondre à ces enjeux en
appliquant davantage des parlementaires
sur la question démocratique d'ailleurs
je tiens à saluer l'adoption d'un
amendement majeur proposé notamment par
Julien Bayou et soutenu par le groupe
socialiste qui permet la création d'une
commission de parlementaire d'évaluation
sur les exportations d'armement enfin
nous devons également souligner dans
suffisance de cette LPM sur les enjeux
climatiques l'un des grands l'une des
plus grandes menaces à laquelle
l'humanité a été confrontée il est clair
que pour y faire face tous les secteurs
de notre société doivent évoluer y
compris nos forces armées ce n'est pas
seulement une question de responsabilité
environnementale mais aussi de sécurité
nationale nos collègues au du Sénat du
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
en particulier Guillaume comptard et
Mélanie Vogel on s'y fait un travail et
fait adopter des amendements pour que
tous les Français qui souhaitent
intégrer nos armées ils trouvent leur
place ils ont ainsi fait adopter
l'interdiction de mentionner
l'orientation sexuelle dans le dossier
individuel et on fait définir des
objectifs de féminisation de nos armées
à hauteur de 20% d'ici 2030 nous sommes
convaincus que la diversité des profils
des compétences et des sensibilités est
un facteur d'enrichissement pour nous
nos forces de défense enfin et parce que
c'est quand même une loi de
programmation financière vont dire nous
votons un budget en augmentation de 40%
pour nos armées nous en avons besoin
c'est une vérité nous avons besoin
d'augmenter cet effort financier mais
tant d'autres services publics ont
besoin également et c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que moi je ne comprends pas
nous avons un ministre du Budget qui où
je fais le tour des journaux pour
annoncer une nouvelle cure de stérilité
alors que les Français subissent
toujours de plein cela est profondément
injuste mais au-delà de ça monsieur le
ministre vous le savez dans une période
de conflit dans une période
d'incertitude le soutien d'un peuple aux
décisions de ces dirigeants et cruciales
et indispensables et après l'attitude
que vous avez eu sur les retraites après
l'attitude que vous avez aujourd'hui sur
les manifestations continuez à provoquer
avec cette cure de stérilité c'est
continuer à rompre le lien de confiance
entre les Français et leur représentants
alors je vous le dis par votre
aveuglement c'est votre pays que vous
fragilisez
et nous c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que nous nous abstradons sur ce texte
merci madame la députée
nous appelons maintenant procédé au
scrutin je vais donc mettre voilà la
proposition de loi je vous prie de bien
vouloir regagner vos places le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin
votant 286 exprimés 281 majorité 141
pour 244 contre 37 l'Assemblée nationale
a adopter la séance est suspendue pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]